bruno bartocetti bonjour
nos journées c'est de m'avoir invité
merci de nous répondre ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france on le disait à
poitiers emmanuel macron lance donc les
états généraux de la justice comment en
tant que policier vous percevez cette
initiative du chef de l'état
alors bien évidemment on va trouver
l'initiative très intéressante puisque
je crois qu'il va louer ce qui ne
trompent pas lui dit de 4 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires pour la justice
parce que ça a été dit dans votre
témoignage est les témoignages qui ont
été recueillis dans la rue est ce que la
justice a les moyens de fonctionner
aujourd'hui
mais la première question si vous le
permettez qu'on peut se poser c'est est
ce que est ce que la prison aujourd'hui
parce que la prison fait peur c'est la
première question qu'on doit se poser
vous savez un france je vous le dis
parce que bien sûr en zone sud je
connais bien des endroits sensibles
comme marseille où on a de nombreux
règlements de comptes et biens à
l'endroit des dealers nous avons la
peine de mort qui existe leur espérance
de vie ne dépasse pas 30 ans donc nous
avons une société qui est bien malade et
on pointe du doigt le travail de la
police le travail de la justice
nous demandons où plus de moyens pour
travailler police et justice mais je
crois qu'il va falloir aussi travaillé
au sein de notre société pour éviter
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de délais
dans ça c'est le premier volet notre
volet important parmi parmi les mba
tironi aider l'école sanctionné vous
avez peu près du tiers de récidivistes
donc est ce que la prison pour régler
les problèmes il faut bien sûr
sanctionné il faut emprisonnés mais le
mal est plus profond je pense on se
souvient de cette grande manifestation
le 19 mai dernier des dizaines de
et de policiers de vos confrères
s'étaient rassemblés devant l'assemblée
nationale le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin étaient venus d'ailleurs
ce jour là et il y avait un site au
grand c'est le problème de la police
c'est la justice c'est ce que vous
dénoncez toujours
alors ça avait été dit par une de mes de
mes collègues de sediqa différent du
mien mais bon je suis pas là pour juger
ces propos on peut pas directement dire
le problème c'est la justice c'est trop
facile il y a un problème dans la
justice de fonctionnement c'est évident
puisque eux mêmes je parle des
magistrats demain dans les moyennes de
sanctionner vous savez nous sommes en
relation
régulièrement avec des magistrats
demandé aujourd'hui à un enquêteur il
vous expliquera que régulièrement des
temps en contact avec avec un magistrat
et les grandes difficultés que l'on a
pour travailler ce sont les lourdeurs
des procédures le nombre de délégués en
france et qui augmente ce n'est pas à
cause de la justice ou à cause de la
police et donc on peut pas pointer du
doigt en disant le problème c'est la
justice ou alors la police se tue c'est
quand même très populiste de tenir ce
genre de propos pour notre part à unité
sgp police nous nous demandons
effectivement beaucoup plus de d'être de
de communication à l'endroit des
citoyens pour qu'ils comprennent comment
fonctionne une institution comme celle
de la justice comme celle de la police
et puis peut-être aussi regarder ça a
été dit dans les témoignages recueillis
dans la rue peut-être que aujourd'hui
c'est le grand problème à présent c est
ce que le prisonnier est là pour purger
une peine ou est-ce qu'il est là pour
atteindre finalement ou de moins de
trois mois sortir en se mettant sur son
cv j'ai fait trois mois de prison j'ai
pu fumer du shit en prison j'ai fait mon
téléphone est en prison c'est ça le
problème justement ce que vous nous
disiez c'est qu'aujourd'hui selon vous
la prison bien ça ne fait plus peur pour
pour les délinquants alors du coup à
quoi servent ces états généraux de la
justice finalement si selon vous le
problème il va au delà puisque c'est le
problème que le délinquant n'a plus peur
d'aller en prison
voilà juste j'espère que ce sera ce sera
abordée bien sûr sur ceux sur les
étagères la justice c'est un sujet très
très important
je passe à nos politiques s'étaient dit
encore une fausse identité dans les
témoignages est vraiment vous avez
recueilli un panel de témoignages
intéressants je pense que nos politiques
devraient s'intéresser sur ce sujet
plutôt que travailler dans la
récupération et dans le populisme
parfois pour certains en tout cas élu de
la république ou qu'il est qui qui
souhaitent l'être
prends un exemple en matière de prison
alors que ça cesse ses prisons cesse
d'augmenter je veux dire les prisonniers
sont sans cesse en augmentation pardon
est ce qu'aujourd'hui pour que cette
prison ce soit dissuasive est ce que
l'on est ce que l'on a c'est de
prisonniers qui travaillent en prison je
mens pas je crois qu'il ya à peu près
20% je crois qu'il faut vraiment
abandonné 1 prison faire prendre
conscience aux délinquants qui doivent
une dette à la société et certainement
pas se faire ce faire un cd pour dire
regardez j'ai fait trois mois de prison
donc d'elle pour essayer de répondre à
votre question les états généraux sur la
justice c'est un sujet très intéressant
mais ça se limitera pas en termes de
moyens financiers c'est à dire que ce
que vous attendez vous comme mesures
concrètes finalement ces serpents sénat
car ces rations aujourd'hui oui voilà
c'est ça c'est vraiment réfléchir
réfléchir comment aujourd'hui en prison
on peut on peut dissuader m délicat de
dire obtenir ou d'être en grosse
actionné est-ce qu'on donne assez de
moyens aussi aux au gardien de prison
pour travailler c'est compliqué pour eux
c'est très difficile ils sont ils sont
peut-être pris encore plus pris en otage
que ces prisonniers
est ce que c'est normal qu'il y ait
autant de parloir sauvage est ce que
c'est normal qu'il y ait autant
finalement entre guillemets autant de
liberté en prison pour ces prisonniers
alors je parle pas du ballet on est bien
d'accord il faut que la sanction soit
prononcée avec une vraie sévérité que
celui qui rentre à présent n'est
vraiment plus envie d'y retourner c'est
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas la
prison ne fait pas peur ça c'est une
évidence pour beaucoup en tout cas
vous savez qui a peur d'aller en prison
c'est finalement le le le je sais pas
l'automobiliste est qu a perdu les
points sur son permis et qui continue à
rouler là pour pour aller travailler
c'est lui il a peur de la prison le 20
heures de deux de cocaïne de cannabis
n'a pas peur d'aller en prison c'est pas
vrai on entend souvent les politiques
dire il faut tout simplement appliquer
les peines prévues par le code pénal est
ce que si on les applique à la lettre
finalement ça pourrait être une mesure
vous qui qui vous semblerait faisable
oui c'est une mesure c'est une mesure
bien sûr c'est une piste à retenir aussi
je suis pas d'un angélisme en disant
qu'il faut passer à autre chose qu'à la
prison je crois que ce qui est important
à l'endroit des récidivistes c'est
qu'ils purgent leur peine et surtout
surtout que la peine soit immédiate ce
n'est pas normal qu'on attende parfois
en vain d'être ou un ou deux ans d'être
convoqué en justice pour insultes à voir
en rappel à la loi c'est important c'est
en temps réel être sanctionné
immédiatement l'os koné a commis une
peine sanctionnable c'est ça qui est
important c'est que immédiatement le
délai qu'a se rende compte de la faute
qu'il a commise si c'est pour attendre
non mais après partir sur une leçon de
morale et laissez-le finalement le temps
à l'avocat de travailler sur sa défense
dans le sas ou pendant une année ou deux
en attendant d'être convoqués au
tribunal on a très bien la possibilité
de 2 voilà deux de trouver un travail de
devenir père de famille qui après on est
blanchi de toute sanction non c'est
important d'être sanctionné dans les
médias dans l'immédiat à prévoir après
commis un acte de délinquance et pour
cela il faut du coup plus de places de
prison valérie pécresse exprimé sur le
sujet hier et pour elle veut elle veut
créer des centres fermés dans les
anciennes casernes vous en pensez quoi
pourquoi pas ça peut être une piste
intéressante en tout cas c'est sûr que
que je crois que vous avez 15 me de
bracelets en france je loge sous réserve
je voudrais pas dire de bêtises mais
est-ce qu est-ce qui sont utilisés
efficacement dans de bonnes conditions
en tout cas les conditions nécessaires
pour sanctionner jeu ne sais pas l'idée
de l'erythrée pts précresse paraphant
excusez moi mais peut-être une idée
intéressante mais voilà je crois qu'il
faut vraiment passer sur sur du long
terme et met immédiatement c'est de
pouvoir vraiment mettre les personnes en
prison qui mérite d'être sanctionné et
pour cela il faut s'en donner les moyens
est-ce qu'il faut élargir les prisons
est ce qu'il faut en construire d'autres
pourquoi pas c'est une piste est aussi
intéressantes à retenir merci à vous
bruno bartocetti d'un stand répondu à
nos questions ce matin je le rappelle
vous êtes secrétaire soupçonne sud paca
corse aussi dany sgp police fo